[Musique]
madame monsieur bonsoir je voudrais
regarder la France au fond des yeux
à votre place un peu moins mais si vous
réussissez pas ce qu'il vous manque une
seule chose à tout petit détail le sexe
comme chaque semaine France Info Elina
vous offre un voyage dans le temps à
travers les archives de la télévision
pour mieux comprendre l'actualité
contemporaine Céline attendu et vous
êtes les bienvenus à mes côtés Camille
d'Auxerre et Géraldine cornet Lavau
journaliste à la rédaction de Lina
bonjour à toutes les deux alors
aujourd'hui nous allons parler du marché
de Noël de Strasbourg et de la
présidentielle comment annoncer sa
candidature un c'est un sujet diablement
d'actualité et Jacques Séguéla est là
pour nous en parler mais d'abord notre
revue de presse hebdomadaire Géraldine
cette semaine voulez nous parler de
musique et d'un d'un artiste qui vous
tient à cœur Étienne Daho Étienne je
suis fan vous aussi j'adore il fait ses
40 ans de carrière a effectivement
l'album mythomane est sorti en
1981 alors pour l'occasion il leur ai
dit il sort à nouveau single de live
inédit et surtout l'Académie française
lui remets la médaille la grande
médaille de la chanson française pour
l'ensemble de sa carrière rien que ça
voulez-vous montrer merci qui date un
peu qui date de 1985 il en est à ses
débuts et il nous explique quel genre de
musique il fait qu'est-ce que c'est que
Étienne Daho chanteur
[Musique]
dans la chambre à Lyon
voilà tout déchirer est l'expression
être un
tout autre chose car il y a un mois un
mouvement et est né en Belgique balance
ton bar oui #balance ton bar et c'est un
mouvement qui a fait des émules en
France des victimes ont rapporté des cas
d'agression dans des bars dans des
boîtes de nuit et une drogue et mise en
cause le GHB qui est aussi appelé la
drogue du violeur et après de 20 ans en
2002 la présence de cette drogue était
déjà très prise au sérieux dans les
boîtes de nuit c'est une nouvelle drogue
venu des États-Unis le GHB dont l'usage
est en forte progression fait de plus en
plus de ravages surnommée la drogue des
violeurs utilisé dans les boîtes de nuit
mais aussi dans les soirées privées elle
provoque un état de soumission et
d'amnésie les agresseurs Anvers dans le
verre de leur victime avant d'abuser
d'elle dans de nombreuses boîte de nuit
on a pris conscience du danger
ici par exemple on a décidé de réagir
[Musique]
mesure de sécurité c'est couvercle à la
fois dissuasif et rassurant le GHB c'est
moins répandu que la plupart des drogues
il représente mais en moins un danger
qui appelle à la vigilance
j'entends plus tard le capuchon sur le
verre tu es toujours l'une des solutions
pour économiser pour se protéger en
boîte de nuit
et donc l'extrait du nom de cette
émission pour l'actualité de cette
semaine alors que s'est-il passé à cette
même période de l'année par le passé
pour le savoir il suffit de regarder le
zapping de l'inattendu
Bonjour
et une consultation populaire pour en
arriver là la finale de la Coupe du
monde de football aura lieu au Stade de
France c'est la dernière ligne droite de
ceux qui ont déjà 1200 km dans les
jambes
Nelson Mandela notre bien-aimé Nelson
Mandela
le président fondateur de notre nation
démocratique est décédé
[Applaudissements]
173 ans après Napoléon Bonaparte
l'empereur Bokassa 1er porte en couronne
7 épées et manteau de cours à officiel
m'en prêter serment
François Mitterrand est inauguré cet
après-midi le musée d'Orsay une
réalisation engagé par Georges Pompidou
est poursuivi par Valéry Giscard
d'Estaing ce que le chef de l'État c'est
plus à signaler
l'exemple continue et statique il était
le plus grand violoniste de jazz et
c'est lui qui avait introduit cet
instrument plutôt classique dans le
monde du swing
[Musique]
Bonsoir bonne soirée
les grands enfants que nous sommes ont
le sourire nous sommes enfin au mois de
décembre et noël approche à grand pas
alors cette année l'inattendu a choisi
de vous entraîner sur l'un des lieux les
plus emblématiques de cette période
festive le marché de Noël de Strasbourg
70 de dollars démarche est le plus vieux
les Strasbourgeois dérange c'est le
marché de Noël le plus vieux à l'époque
40570 un peu d'histoire Strasbourg et un
bastion du protestantisme alors pour se
démarquer des catholiques la
municipalité lance le marché de
l'Enfant-Jésus ça se dit tenez vous bien
j'ai révisé avec un collègue
strasbourgeois Chris Kindles Méric
j'espère que j'ai bien dit alors c'est
bien évolué depuis 1570 ans dit et même
si cette année la ville de Strasbourg
veux un marché authentique est
responsable je cite il est de fête
devenue une grande foire commerciale
tous les ans à Strasbourg pendant les 15
jours qui précèdent Noël se tient place
Broglie le Christ Kindle se marie le
marché de Noël
dans les années 60
Strasbourg dure donc seulement 15 jours
et il est concentré sur une seule place
en vente des bredele du vin chaud des
sapins et de quoi les décorer vous êtes
donc le doyen des vendeurs de sapin
depuis lors la Foire de Noël déploie ses
fast Populaire coloré brillant Florent
bon la pâtisserie
le berlingot
ici place Brive
dans Noël un tant soit peu matérialiste
la critique sera encore plus féroce dans
les années 80 le bon vieux père Noël
mais pas si vieux que cela s'entend à
peine le temps pour les adultes de créer
avec l'accord de tous un nouveau RIB
qu'il fasse riz mes enfants avec argent
fin des années 90 première alerte est-ce
que ce marché séculaire ne va pas perdre
son âme à vouloir toujours plus grand
toujours plus de chiffre d'affaires non
pour certains il faudrait même en faire
plus pour permettre champ de profiter à
fond du marché de Noël il faudrait
l'étendre a plusieurs mois donc créer
une espèce de Noël Landes où toute
l'année on pourrait voir les petites
baraques de Noël voir des gens qui qui
dans la rue avec les bonnets-rouges
comme on a les oreilles de Mickey chez
Mickey le marché de Noël de Strasbourg
ne se transformera par Disney mais il va
s'étendre de son stand en 1992 300
aujourd'hui l'événement dur maintenant 1
mois et il sait que je porte des 2009 à
Tokyo Moscou New York
[Musique]
aujourd'hui de Noël de Strasbourg
qui rapporte 250 million d'euros à
l'économie locale
alors pour tenter de conserver l'esprit
2570 et éviter le made in China une
charte est édité en 2017
alors mal
l'adjoint à la mairie de l'époque parler
la volonté
mairie de retour
cité du marché de Noël les artisans sont
forcément concurrencer par des forains
avec donc des bonnets lumineux à côté
des petits santons fait main malgré tout
on a bien on a bien compris dans dans ce
sujet c'est un endroit où on aime flâner
un se promener à défaut de pouvoir y
aller on peut toujours regarder certains
reportages dans les journaux télévisés à
la fin des gîtes et parfois même au tout
début du JT ouverture tous les ans il y
a un sujet sur le marché de Noël de
Strasbourg je le fais part en version
cette fois-ci c'est ce qu'on appelle un
marronnier quand un journaliste tous les
ans c'est le même sujet et j'avais envie
pour finir de ce dossier de vous montrer
cette archives elle date de 1987 le
journaliste de France 3 Alsace avec
clairement pas envie de faire un énième
reportage sur le marché de Noël on
écoute ton sujet
cela fait 418 ans que le marché existe
presque autant qu'on va le film est
inutile de vous dire qu'il est place
Broglie qu'il y a une quarantaine de
commerçant autant d'artisan à une
vingtaine de marchand de sapin vous le
savez déjà seul d'ailleurs la conscience
professionnelle et un rédacteur en chef
de très mauvaise humeur nous empêcher de
rester bien au chaud et de vous repassez
les images de l'an passé ou d'il y a 2
ans ou trois ou quatre ou cinq ou six ou
sept ou huit neuf
j'espère qu'il a été muté
les images de l'an passé de 10 à 2 ans 5
ans 10 ans attention les images de donc
on peut pas on peut pas le laisser faire
voilà merci beaucoup en tout cas pour
pour ce beau voyage à Strasbourg comment
vous dites marché de Noël
[Musique]
un petit peu moins de 5 mois avant
l'élection présidentielle tous les
candidats ne sont pas encore déclarer on
a encore vu avec Éric Zemmour un ces
déclarations n'ai jamais anodine ton sur
le fond que sur la forme on parle
d'ailleurs souvent d'acte fondateur et
qui est mieux que Jacques Séguéla
publicitaire pour me parler de ces
moments historiques non non non non je
le pense vraiment vous avez accompagné
François Mitterrand et d'autres dans
leur campagne électorale c'est important
de réussir son entrée en scène sa
candidature et tout est important dans
une campagne et surtout le démarrage à
l'époque c'était très important parce
que la télévision dit que c'est tout
aujourd'hui réseaux sociaux on revient
la télévision à sa place et donc ça n'a
pas l'importance que ça a eu pour pour
de Gaulle pour jusqu'à pour le dernier
en date c'est Éric Zemmour mardi qui
dans une vidéo sur Youtube a déclaré sa
candidature il a repris justement les
codes du Général de Gaulle en parlant
assis à un bureau devant son micro en
lisant son texte vous en avez pensé quoi
cette déclaration
de français 3 jours après
parce que une fois de plus une fois de
plus une fois
donc
tu
peux pas faire n'importe quoi
on va essayer de ne pas parler que de
lui
donner quelques déclaration de
candidature
regarder toutes les déclarations
on a essayé de prendre un petit peu
Histoire du pays d'abord donc toutes les
personnalités sans revendiquent leurs le
général de Gaulle en
1965 il est président sortant il se
représente aux potes et surtout c'est la
première fois qu'un président va être
élu au suffrage universel direct en
France il se présente au journal de 20h
depuis l'Élysée nous sommes le 4
novembre 65 un mois et 1 jours avant le
premier tour une allocution de 9 minutes
30 que les Français vous voyez vous
regardez de manière très sérieuse depuis
des cafés dans la rue dont voici un
extrait aujourd'hui
je crois devoir
me tenir prêt à poursuivre ma tâche
mesure en connaissance de cause
de quel effort il s'agit
mais convaincu que actuellement
c'est le mieux pour servir la France que
l'adhésion franche et massive des
citoyens
m'engage à rester en fonction
l'avenir de la République nouvelle sera
décidément t'assurer sinon
ça ne peut douter
qu'elle se collera aussitôt alors cette
déclaration c'est non
finalement il y a que lui qui pouvait la
faire bien comprendre une chose la
télévision c'est 50 % le carré de la
télévision sur un coup en avant c'est
agressif encore en arrière
répressif
20 % c'est la gestuelle
et le dis ce n'est plus que 15 % et
c'est simplement parce que le lendemain
les journalistes sont le reprendre et
cetera beaucoup de te le dis va refaire
surface
[Musique]
Jacques Chirac François Mitterrand
Valéry Giscard d'Estaing Valéry Giscard
d'Estaing qui qui a tenté d'être proche
des Français Camilla pour ces
candidatures oui en
1974 il est ministre de Pompidou il se
présente depuis Chamalieres son fief
dans la mairie donc du Puy-de-Dôme et il
veut comme il dit il reprend ses mots
regarder la France au fond des yeux
est-ce que c'est malin Jacques Séguéla
se présenter en province oui parce que
c'est la province qui décide c'est pas
rien quand même aller plus haut par
80 il il se présente un second et c'est
toi qui se présente depuis Paris oui
depuis Paris et puis surtout regarder
vous allez voir sur fond neutre et si
j'ose dire avec pour seule décor un
bouquet de fleurs et sa femme
de me présenter à l'élection
présidentielle
pour un septennat nouveau
pendant 7 ans
mon devoir d'État
et la réserve nécessaire à ma fonction
monte interdit de m'exprimer en toute
liberté
enfin je vais pouvoir vous dire d'homme
à homme ce que j'ai dans l'esprit et sur
le cœur je ne serais pas un président
candidats mais un citoyen candidat on
entendu un s'exprimer librement le
regard franc dire ce qu'il a dans
l'esprit et sur le cœur et Giscard
d'Estaing très bien les ficelles de la
communication politique trop bien
la première fois il était naturel la
première
et la deuxième fois j'ai l'impression
que c'est même pas la peine qui se
présente ça va continuer il fait tout
d'abord
sa femme les Français
en couple ils ne veulent pas voir la
femme dans le couple à l'époque c'était
ça pour pas l'oublier et deuxièmement il
était à la mode il a créé la mode dans
sa première candidature pour tout d'un
coup il apparaît démodé tu as parlé
démodé démodé à l'image même aujourd'hui
on voit bien que la première déclaration
et plus et plus dans le goût du jour que
la seconde une déclaration d'intention
français ça doit se faire avec le cœur
et là c'est fait avec la tête je vous
allez voir Mitterrand vous allez voir me
tarde de voir la différence aller voir
là où là tu es alors justement j'allais
vous dire votre nom est indissociable de
celui de François Mitterrand et j'en
suis fait la force tranquille de 81 C
vous alors la campagne
j'ai jamais écrit ça sur un papier du
président fermé les yeux les yeux j'ai
vu qu'il est comme ça dans le texte il
m'a dit c'est de la vous m'avez trouvé
réussi c'est le seul qui trouve 100 €
alors
si vous voulez ou pas
je n'ai pas me présenter
son cancer les beaucoup souffrir ce
héros car qui va le faire mais je
voudrais que ce soit vous qui va sur les
campagnes de retard il me raccompagne
est sur le chemin et il me dit mais on
sait jamais peut-être que regard peut
refuser peut-être qu'il pourrait faire
quelque chose donc il faut que la fiche
que vous allez faire serre barreau
carnet me servent aussi à l'affiche de
yaourt voiture choisir vous avez des
idées
la première affiche politique où on ne
voit pas le politicien
remplacé par quelque chose j'ai remplacé
par ma petite fille avait 1 ans avec le
slogan génération Mitterrand qui servait
à Roquefort aussi bien à 8h en tout cas
cette cette campagne a marqué pour ton
et vous venez de m'expliquer pourquoi
Camille il a mis du temps à déclarer le
dernier moment écoute extrait du journal
de 13h d'Antenne 2 on est le 4 mars 1988
le premier tour et le 24 avril et
François Mitterrand ne veux toujours pas
dire si les oui ou non candidat je suis
pas je veux garder mon autorité le plus
longtemps possible ou notamment sur la
scène internationale je le suis pas.
Quand même 4 mois à l'avance 3 mois
avant
très longtemps avant de la prendre alors
ça c'est parce que c'est lui qui a
inventé
jour après l'extrait combien de voir le
22 mars un mois et 1 jours avant le
premier tour je serai le dernier
journaliste de France et de Navarre à
vous poser cette question c'est le
président êtes-vous un nouveau candidat
à la présidence de la République
le plus jeune fille le cristal à
merveille vous avez mûrement réfléchi
j'ai le droit de savoir quand vous avez
pris cette décision certains 17 en
juillet 8717 pendant les fêtes de fin
d'année je n'en sais rien moi-même
il était préparé ce oui ou par non
et j'ai dit oui
et
puis aussi
1981 il se présente à la présidentielle
communiqué de presse
de l'hôtel de ville de Paris
c'est une candidature depuis son bureau
par la presse régionale La Voix du Nord
et il était né en 95 et enfin en 2002 il
se présente de manière faussement prévu
en février 2 mois et demi avant le
premier tour dans une gare à Avignon
depuis quelques jours
je ne peux pas faire en pas hors de chez
moi ou de ma mairie sans qu'on me pose
de la question
et je crois que cette question on se la
pose par tout en France le président
va-t-il déclarer sa candidature
cher
je vous l'ai dit vous m'avez posé une
question directe et franche
bien j'y répondrai dans le même esprit
oui je suis Candy
alors c'est une opération de comme
formidable regarder juste de Jacques
Séguéla ces images de son retour à Paris
7 minutes de journalistes qui l'attend
sur le quai du train vous m'avez dit en
préparant cette émission que c'était la
meilleure candidature à la
présidentielle pourquoi parce que c'est
sa fille il a fait rire sans sa fille et
sans sa famille Chirac n'aurait pas été
c'est elle qui a décidé de prendre la
campagne en mains écartées tous les
publicitaires autour de lui et qui a
réglé chaque image une dernière
déclaration à vous montrer Jacques
Séguéla c'est celle du président actuel
Emmanuel Macron cette fois on est en
2016 quand ils se présentent il est
ancien ministre de l'Économie il se
présente font que moi avant le premier
tour dans un centre de formation en
scène 5 il a rédigé sa déclaration dans
la nuit ce matin le temps et solennelle
je suis candidat à la présidence de la
République
parce que je crois plus que tout que
nous pouvons réussir lui il devait
parler le plus tôt possible parce qu'il
fallait que les médias l'accompagne en
tant que président l'arrivée de nulle
part personne ne le connaissez j'avais
été ministre en coup de vent donc il
fallait absolument qu'il est le temps
d'affirmer mettre son costume de
président qui d'ailleurs va se révéler
au Louvre le jour de son élection donc
si tu me quittes une radiation ça a été
très bien fait mais sans publicitaires
donc ça c'est très bas là
mais peut-être qu'il va quand même
trouvé une autre façon de nous
surprendre parce que la surprise fait
partie de la campagne présidentielle
mais quelques semaines vous avez été
surpris Jacques Séguéla en train de
glisser justement à l'oreille du
président des mots comme quoi vous avez
un slogan pour lui pensé à quoi
non ça veut dire qu'il va le reprendre
je ne sais pas je ne sais pas
mais
merci
pour cet éclairage et votre vision de
campagne présidentielle
grand plaisir nous on se quitte avec
notre traditionnel Pépita lundi c'est la
Saint-Nicolas dans l'Est de la France et
être Saint-Nicolas ce n'est pas si
évident que ça aujourd'hui 6 décembre
nous fêtons Saint-Nicolas disons-le
Tounet Saint-Nicolas notre BonPatron
vite une journée beaucoup plus
éreintante que celle du Père Noël le 25
décembre porter une barbe en laine ou en
coton hydrophile en vrai cheveux ou en
crin de cheval ou un fil plastique
calmer les pleurs des bambins apeuré par
le Père Fouettard vilain venu de te
retrouver la fête hein je me demande
parfois si vraiment vraiment la
sanctification ce n'est pas l'enfer
quand on se nomme Saint-Nicolas et qu'on
se promène sur un char
parler Merci à VOUS camilia pour ce ce
dossier on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine sur le canal 27 toute la
semaine sur les réseaux sociaux ce soit
ce de Lina ou de France Info émission
préparer avec les documentaliste
Florence tu sais qui a brûlé et néon
gala merci à elle et merci à vous d'être
là chaque semaine
[Musique]